what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson thanks for stopping by
the channel today we have some really
big news for two types of fans one
Marvel and Captain America fans but two
WWE fans and I know there are a lot of
them out there and today we have learned
that WWE star Seth Rollins has joined
the Marvel Cinematic Universe it is
official and we actually do have some
set photos of him on the set of Captain
America 4 New World Order actually right
now it doesn't have a title According to
some insiders Marvel Studios is changing
the title of Captain America new world
order to something else we don't know
what the new title is going to be at
this point in time we just know it's not
actually going to be called New World
Order and this could be because they are
possibly changing some things about the
movie Marvel Studios is kind of under a
massive change up right now they've
gotten rid of some Executives they are
changing the pace at which they release
movies and show shows on Disney plus
which means they are also being a little
bit more selective on what they make TV
shows and movies out of including which
characters they're going to make those
shows and movies after and they were
getting new writers and rewriting some
scripts for some movies Captain America
4 could be one of them but of course
right now the wga is on strike so a lot
of writing is on hold however it does
seem like most of it has been completed
for New World Order perhaps some changes
are coming but they are filming right
now we do have some set photos like I
mentioned giving us a new look at
Captain America Sam Wilson's Captain
America and Seth Rollins's new character
and another new character that we're
going to go over in this video and it
does seem like we do know who Seth
Rollins is going to be playing also just
want to say big thank you to all the
patrons that we've got so far on our new
patreon account we super appreciate any
and all support you give us we do put
some exclusive content on the patreon so
we'll link that down below if you're
interested we also have a website and a
Discord if you want to join a community
with other awesome people and of course
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and we'll talk about our giveaway at the
end of the video so this report about
Seth Rollins being cast in Captain
America New World Order we'll just call
it that for now until we know the new
title but I believe the news was first
broken by my buddies at one take news
and then I think shortly after that we
got the Set photo which we'll put on
screen right here and as you can see it
is official Seth Rollins has been cast
he is filming right now for Captain
America 4. he's filming with another
character that we're about to talk about
but let's talk about who Seth Rollins is
actually playing in the MCU now and we
do have a new look at Sam Wilson's
Captain America with a new suit so we'll
also be diving into that today now we
have information on both of these new
characters thanks to Lizzy Hill over at
thecosmiccircus.com and she stated on
Twitter that per her sources earlier
this year Seth Rollins is either playing
Cobra or constrictor now we'll start
with Cobra Cobra is in fact a Captain
America villain in the comics although
he is mainly known for being a Thor or
Daredevil villain but he has come in
contact with Captain America and
Spider-Man in the comics he's gone by
many names one is simply Cobra one is
the Cobra and currently right now in the
comics he is king cobra but he's also
gone by the name human Cobra his real
name is Klaus Voorhees he's from the
Netherlands and basically he has the
powers of a king cobra snake Klaus
Voorhees was an ex-convict and he was a
laboratory assistant for a professor in
India who was looking for a cure for
venomous snake bites however Voorhees
didn't like the position that he had as
simply an assistant so he killed the
professor in hopes to steal his
discoveries and he killed him by having
a snake bite him but he also felt that
he was probably going to be questioned
about everything and might even be
accused as the person who killed him so
in order to look less guilty he had the
snake bite him as well he had an
anti-venom on him that he gave to
himself and of course not the scientist
however unfortunately or fortunately the
Cobra that he used was experimented on
in a process that was very similar to
Spider-Man and the spider that gave him
powers and the Cobra gave him cobra-like
Powers so he is extremely flexible he
has a slithery body and of course he's
got the normal superhuman powers like
superhuman strength agility stamina he
can wall crawl and he also has an
arsenal of venomous weapons now
originally they were going to call the
next Captain America film Captain
America's serpent Society but Marvel
Studios kind of scrapped that but
perhaps we could be seeing something
very similar to that movie on screen
when Captain America 4 comes out however
Lizzie Hill also said that he could be
playing constrictor and just based off
the backstory of constrictor it seems
like this is probably more plausible
constrictor's real name was Frank Payne
and he was actually an agent of shield
he was given the assignment by Shield to
go undercover as a costume super villain
to infiltrate the criminal organization
called the corporation he was given to a
snake themed costume a pair of wrist
mounted electrified metal coils he
joined the corporation with a code name
constrictor he infiltrated the group but
then he suffered a mental nervous
breakdown and essentially after that
just became a True Villain and started
working for the corporation until they
were disbanded then he would fight
alongside of other criminal teams like a
member of Justin Hammer's criminal Army
and teaming up with Sabretooth as well
and he would go on to fight many
different Heroes like Spider-Man Luke
Cage Iron Fist but he would fight
Captain America a lot now just given his
backstory as an agent of shield and then
defecting that seems like it fits this
storyline a little bit better but
honestly he could be playing either
character and in these set photos that
we have of him here we don't really see
him wearing any type of coils on his
wrists or on his arms and those are a
big part of the character and the coils
are actually given to him by Justin
hammer and he uses the coils as a way to
constrict people and wrap them up hence
his name now as far as this other person
that he is standing next to that is in a
costume that looks very much like his
this is Diamondback this is also
confirmed by Lizzie Hill and if you look
closely you can actually see a diamond
on her chest and on the back apparently
there's a diamond as well now
Diamondback has a pretty cool story
especially when it comes to Captain
America she was an original member of
the serpent Society her brothers joined
a gang led by a man known as Bing and
she joined as well and Bing would
eventually go on to be crossbones she
would then receive training by Anaconda
at one of task Masters academies then
she would be one of the original members
of The Serpent society and she would go
up against the Avengers and she would up
against Captain America however when she
saw Captain America she was instantly
Smitten by him and essentially fell in
love with him and this started kind of a
conflict with her now she was still a
villain and she would still fight the
heroes but eventually she did switch
sides and eventually her and Captain
America did go on a date however Black
Widow wasn't really aware of this she
wasn't aware that she switched side so
she fought Diamondback but eventually
all was revealed now now one of her
teammates in the serpent Society was
Cobra so that actually could be evidence
that Seth Rollins could indeed be
playing Cobra and even though this might
not be called serpent Society it is kind
of looking like the serpent Society is
going to play some role in Captain
America 4. so two new characters
revealed today for Captain America 4 but
like I also said we get a new look at
Captain America's new suit now according
to The Insider can we get some toast
this is indeed a new Captain America
suit for Captain America 4 and not a new
stealth suit The Insider tweeted my
source from onset of Captain America 4
is confirmed with me that the new cap
suit is a mix of these showing what
appears to be Captain America's suit the
one that he wore in Avengers end game
and other films and a falcon suit that
Sam wore and the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier and The Insider continued to
State still made a vibranium but keeps
the body and Boots of the falcon suit
with more traditional colors like
Steve's suit has the new star logo with
wings no cow unlike the the last one so
brand new look at these characters on
the set of Captain America 4 provided by
at
christo45-951886 credit to them and
hopefully things are going smoothly with
the filming hopefully nothing gets
delayed and hopefully we find out what
the new title is pretty soon but in the
meantime be sure to let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below also don't forget to like the
video and subscribe and leave a comment
to enter our giveaway for a chance to
win a PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner gets to pick one item and we pick
a winner at the end of each month and
big shout out to our recent patrons
Clancy Jones Mr Anderson Sean Connolly
Oliver Figueroa Ryan Peters Ryan Hafner
Jeremy cabrilles the second Corbin nay
Matthew James and Jonathan Hannah we
super appreciate all of your support
thank you so much for supporting the
channel and of course a big thank you to
everybody here on YouTube we appreciate
all your support as well it's what keeps
the channel going so we hope to see you
in the next video as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf